Amy Duggar King opens up about missing  her cousin gingers wedding  the 30 year old reality stars cousin  tied the knot with Jeremy Lolo in  Arkansas  over the weekend surrounded by friends  and family we are overjoyed to announce  that we are now husband and wife  but Amy and her husband Dylan had  previous plans she explained to ET quote  there is no rift between me and my  cousins at all it was just wrong timing  we already had something scheduled  that's something being a trip to the Las  Vegas Strip according to Amy the couple  was in Sin City to attend the 2017 SEMA  Show a convention for specialty car and  auto parts Amy said quote it was Dylan's  dreamed to be a part of it and his truck  was being sponsored though the pair  wasn't in attendance for the special day  genders older brother Josh was making a  rare family appearance following his  high-profile sex scandal last year  you